Oh, I've had some bad core. You mentioned corporates. Oh yeah. Did you do any?
Yeah, I did one over the holidays. Cause I had like seven of them.
They pay amazing. I'd wear tuxedo.
I did a pharmaceutical awards and I just did my clean act act.
I used to open for Seinfeld. Yeah.
And a lady got offended and it happened to be the CEO's wife.
Quave and then he bitched me out and they fired me. Yeah. I love it. Yeah.
But it's just disheartening it these jokes. I've worked on the tonight show.
What do you want? I did a gig at the seller. This guy showed up and he goes,
I like your stuff. You're edgy. You're wrong?
Come do my a country club come roast my country club. So he's like,
he gave me a sheet of like all his employees and all their dirt.
And he's like really zing them. And I show up and I do the mic tap.
Hey everybody, I'm going to do some comedy and they go,
he's going to roast everybody. Sit back. He's got a cigar and a suit. I go, Hey,
bill. And bill stands up and I go, we all know you're on Coke. And Bill's like,
what? And his wife's like, Oh my God, you're supposed to be cleaning.
And the kids are crying and you know, Rob, we all know you're gay.
Just come out already. And this is all the he gave me. Yeah. The place,
you know, the place is in a, in a, in a brouhaha. And I, the guy came back.
He said, get the hell out of here. True story. We're all backwards.
Priority-wise like, you make a Corona virus joke. Nobody cares.
You make a Coby joke. And you're the devil.
But it's like way more people died with Corona. I'm not saying either one is,
these are all hack retards. The industry sucks.
The industry is a bunch of finance costs. They're all just wearing a suit. No,
you know, whatever. But they don't know anything about comedy.
I know about comedy. I'm in the, I'm in the trenches. I'm in the clubs.
Like I hate that. And then they all go. I love Pryor. I love that guy.
I love Carlin. Now you don't name me one bit.
You don't know anything about comedy. You're just,
you're just at work and you want to keep your gig and you want to seem like
you're on the up and up. And you want to seem like you're, uh, you know,
evolved and in the, in, on the right side.
But you don't actually care about funny.
This is the first time I've seen you rattled by the way. I've never, you ever,
you're usually cool. As a cucumber, you look a little,
it's so entitled and narcissist and they can't even see outside their own. God,
God, sorry. I get it, man.
My friend from Whitman mass Joe list, we have a pug.
I love to watch him master Bach. God, my dream. Ooh, he's a, he's a hunk.
Him and his wife. Wouldn't you love to watch them. Yeah, answer freaky too, man.
They said if an ant was our size, it would be faster than a Ferrari.
I find that odd. You have a goat.
Wow.
The speed is cool. But this car looks silly to.
Me.
And over the top, I don't know it's to me, this is not safe.
Yeah. This is like a joke to me. You're not wrong, but you. I don't care.
Retarded.